[Music]
and good morning welcome to the no bs
podcast here on rt.com i'm your host ben
swann it is 11
a.m eastern time here in the united
states and today we're going to be
talking about this
issue of um activist athletes a lot of
them have been making the news as of
late i'm sure that you've known this
it's really been something
uh that we've talked about for years uh
because of you know going all the way
back to
2014 we're talking about people like
colin kaepernick uh who obviously
made a huge name for himself not only in
the nfl
being a a super bowl competing
quarterback but also
when he began to take a stand uh against
standing up for the national anthem
and since that time we've seen a lot of
athletes who have taken on activism it's
become kind of a new norm but this past
week we saw something
uh take place that's kind of
regenerating a lot of the conversation
surrounding athletes and activism and it
was a young woman by the name of gwyn
berry
who was competing at a nationals the u.s
nationals tournament
came in third in this hammer throw and
then when the national anthem began to
play
she actually turned her body away uh
from the flag and began to
make faces she rolled her eyes she stood
looking
somewhat disgusted there's been a lot of
controversy about this including
discussions
uh by some members of congress that she
should not be allowed
on the u.s olympic team that instead it
should only be for people reserved for
people
who love their country that's the claim
that's been made but here's a question
for you
and we're going to dig into this
question today does
that mean you don't love your country to
challenge your country to
question your country to have problems
with parts of your country's history
does that mean that you don't love your
country we have a panel that will be
joining us
multiple interviews uh that we'll be
getting into today because i think this
is a
a serious question that we really do
need to continue to to dig deeper on and
then of course
on top of all of this is the question of
the anthem itself because there is a
history with the us national anthem
a history that many people don't know uh
a third verse to that anthem
uh that is rarely uh and almost never
sung
it's not part of what we typically uh
you know what we know of as the anthem
for most people
but there is a history there so we're
going to get into all that today it is a
complicated issue
and we're going to bring in our first
guest to talk about it anthony rogers
wright he is a national
racial and climate justice advocate and
he joins us this morning welcome to the
no
bs podcast anthony uh thanks for being
with us
so much for having me it's really great
to meet you
likewise let's talk a little bit about
uh this this latest controversy
uh gwen berry obviously you know she as
we mentioned came in third in this
this hammer throw and it was her
reaction
on that podium that's gotten a lot of
attention uh far
more attention than than would normally
go to
um athletes at this particular event i
would think uh and one of the things she
did you know it was the posturing it was
the turning away and at one point
i think she even put a t-shirt over her
head that said activist
athlete how did you see this happening
i i was extremely proud of the sister um
um continuing the tradition
of um civic-minded athletes going back
to the great muhammad ali of course
frankston uh calls in the 68
mexico city um olympics and i'm just
really um evoking this idea that the era
of shut up and run shut up and dribble
shut up and catch
shut up and throw is absolutely over um
and especially seeing uh that kind of
temerity
from a black woman who worked her butt
off to get onto that podium
so saying hey look i'm representing a
country
that still is not fulfilling its ideals
or it's uh stated ideals as you were
just saying
with the uh the national anthem even and
um it was
it was a very very proud moment not just
for um black americans but i think for
every uh one from the united states who
really believes in free speech
and believes in people standing up for
their ideals and what they believe in
now i i don't want to come off uh you
know insensitive to
you know where someone will come in in
their own personal journey but
you mentioned some of these kind of
historic defining moments
in sports uh that are extremely
significant right you have that that
closed fist
uh during the olympics which you know
back in in the i believe it was what the
1960s where we saw that happen
and in these incredible iconic moments
where someone is taking a stand
to me personally it feels very different
in what we're seeing today
and part of the reason for that is
because for those athletes there was
without question a cost that came with
that there was a certain level of
bravery it took
even though i think you know we we it's
hard for me to debate someone's bravery
you know whether or not when barry was
being brave or not but the behavior
seemed less brave and more so
i'm using a term that others have used
bratty that she came off bratty
instead of like a serious athlete who
was trying to to put forward a serious
message
where am i getting that wrong yeah i
mean
i'm sure that there are plenty of people
who have that narrative i would argue
some of that narrative is rooted a bit
in misogynoir
um it's really hard for us to say uh
what what a person's intentions are um
clearly she did put herself at risk
because here we are talking about it on
your great uh program right now
it has become a part of the lexicon and
conservative uh
talk shows and radio shows um but i i i
guess that it could also be deriving
from this
idea that things have gotten so much
better since 68 since
ali's um era as well but um from what
context are we talking about
this is a young african-american woman
who is alive right now
and while there might not be jim crow
where there might not be
uh profound um white supremacy although
we have seen
acts of profound white supremacy as well
um from her context we are still seeing
unarmed black brown indigenous people
being killed and assassinated by the
state
we are still seeing unequal pay for
black brown and indigenous women
and we are still seeing um um attacks
and
a dangerous culture for transgender uh
black women and we are still seeing
a culture of abuse for um indigenous
specifically
missing and murdered indigenous women so
um i i don't think that we can really
say that things have gotten so much
better from the context
of this young sister's life things are
not that much uh uh
better uh from where we are and i might
add that um you know she's doing this at
a time
when 43 states in in the united states
right now
are trying to pass laws that would make
it a lot harder for people
who look like that athlete to be able to
exercise their right to vote so
um i i don't know that i can agree that
it was coming from
you know a sense of individual brat
brattiness as much as hey
i have a platform i'm going to stand up
on it and i'm going to use it
well and okay let's talk about a couple
of those points because i i i see
when she's talking about from that
platform right uh
what is the stance though what is the
stance specifically that she's taken i
think that's getting lost now maybe
there is
a clear stance that she is taking and
perhaps it's because because media loves
to
to conflate and confuse it's what i
think media does best
uh that message is not getting through
but what is the message because clearly
with
with kaepernick for instance you know
whether you agreed with kaepernick or
not
you knew what he was kneeling for why
was he refusing to stand it was clear
i'm not getting a clear sense of what
she is actually
uh protesting here what is her protest
other than from the quotes i've seen
you know some of the phraseology is a
bit off-putting including phrases like
you know the fact that the national
anthem was played while she was up on
the
the podium she was waiting to take
pictures and she says they knew it would
annoy me
as if this was being played specifically
to target her there's just
there seems like there's a bit of a
difference or maybe it's it's bad
messaging
but do you know what specifically is her
stance um
as an activist athlete that she's
standing up for
yeah no i think that's a fair question
and i i would not pretend to speak
for a black woman i was raised by one
and you know you can get yourself in
trouble with that
but you know if i were to make an
inference though i think it it's the
same thing
as what we saw in mexico city in 68 this
idea that i'm going to go represent my
country in in this case in in
japan and um you know this national
anthem is going to be played
at also at a time when we are
criticizing um many other nations
whether it's
um the people's republic of china um the
revolutionary republic of iran
you know and so many others for their
human rights abuses
and here we are in in our own nation
where we have a
a a population of people or various
populations of people
especially black and indigenous who are
not getting those full human rights
that were guaranteed supposedly in the
14th amendment of the constitution of
the united states of america
so i i think that the message that she's
trying to send is to the world
as well as to um her government her her
government
which she's a for uh who work for her
right they're her employees
of saying hey i'm not gonna go um around
the world and represent our nation
without telling the full truth and the
full truth is that we have so
much more work to do it there are some
people who believe that last summer
um in this nation may as well as not
have happened
because we are still seeing unarmed
killings of black brown and indigenous
uh uh
women and men and and i think that the
message is clear
i'm going to use my platform to show the
world and show
um show our country and show my people
back home
that you know i i'm not just an athlete
i'm also a black woman i'm also a
citizen of that country
and the things that are happening in
that country are hurting me as a citizen
we we're hearing a lot um especially
right now as i mentioned in the lead up
here specifically
about this idea of the olympics right
that the uh you have these athletes who
go and they represent a country
and then are they representing that
country well i mean the idea and i'll
just i'll put it out obviously as the
united states of america
we strive to be an ideal for other
countries it's a bit arrogant to think
that that others should aspire to be
like you are but
you know let's face it that's that's the
american viewpoint right
but the the reality is if you were a
chinese athlete
if you're an iranian athlete if you're
an athlete from from
you know many other virtually any other
country in the world a russian athlete
right
you would never even think about
standing up on a podium
and doing something that would come off
as dismissive or disrespectful
to your country's flag maybe that's a
positive that athletes in this country
can think that way
but on the world stage at that olympic
stage does it send a wrong message it's
not just in the gwen berry case by the
way there was a there's a
a trans athlete who i believe is a um uh
biker i i'm trying to think of what the
exact term is but it's like
you know doing the the bike stuff uh and
essentially has said a couple of years
ago
that she or uh yeah that they wanted to
win
ultimately at the olympics in order to
be able to burn the u.s flag
and has walked back those comments since
then but there is a question about that
right
as an american olympic team should there
be
at least cohesion to say when our flag
is raised
for all the problems that might be in
our country we've got to be in
solidarity together to say it's still a
great country
yeah that's that that's also a fair
question and a very very nuanced one um
we are uh unum right out of many one
that that that is one of the mottos of
this country and and so there so there's
a few things in that question that i
want to unpack
one um going back to the uh words of the
great uh
oakley carmichael uh kwame toure
formerly known as oakley carmichael
and saying that you know we have to get
away from this idea of anglo-conformity
of what is good for the united states is
automatically good for black and
indigenous people
and so what what i'm hearing a lot in
that question i'm not saying that this
is what you were trying to do
but um we are placing the comfort of
white americans
over the issues that are impacting black
and brown and indigenous people that are
making them
very very uncomfortable from police
violence to economic violence um to um
environmental violence right
so um so to that sense you know i'm not
saying that i would necessarily uh burn
the flag and i i take your point
that yes uh we do have the latitude here
to uh to take stands
that some people might not be able to
take in in other countries if they chose
to do
so but that should also be a beacon um
for
for those athletes like we can do this
in our country hopefully eventually you
can do that in
in your country but and so but getting
back to this idea of solidarity
you know i would hope that the uh white
athletes um um who are taking part in
the olympics
would listen to black brown and and and
if there are any indigenous athletes
to say hey look we're about to go and
make tons of money
for uh the united states of america and
for many of um
sponsors and and people who are going to
be uh doing ad buys um we saw how much
money the us
basketball team men's basketball team
has and continues to make for this
country
so maybe you will stay in solidarity
with us because that
flag and that anthem does not represent
the same thing to me as it might to you
listen to what it represents to me to an
indigenous person
that flag represents uh brutal land
theft and genocide of people and to some
people who are the descendants of
african uh slaves
that flag represents stolen bodies raped
african women who were brought here to
build this country for free
and have never been given retribution
just like indigenous people
and broken treaties have never been
given retribution for those treaties
that have been broken so
you know can you can you listen to us
and for those three to five minutes
stand in solidarity and we have seen
that with the uh u.s women's uh
soccer team one of the best teams in the
united states of america i might add
showing that kind of solidarity taking
the knee um
speaking out um against anti-black
racism and i think that um
if anything that could bring the country
together one last thing i'll say
on this point is that you know one of
the greatest acts of defiance that we've
ever seen in the olympics
was by a black man named jesse owens not
only did he go
to um nazi germany to eviscerate the
myopia of this idea of white supremacy
in germany
but he also was sending a message of
look at what i'm doing a black man
in this olympics representing your
country and when i get back home
i'm going to be called the n word i'm
going to be told i have to drink from
another fountain
i'm going to be told i have to go to a
different school that was an amazing act
of defiance
and i think that that's the type of
solidarity that we're uh looking for
today in 2021
when we're talking about the same issues
that uh jesse owens was talking about in
his era
well we are talking about somewhat
different issues but i i mean
certainly the the issues that jesse
owens faced are not the issues that gwen
berry faces
there might be parallels that you can
draw between them but there's certainly
a difference there i will say this i
agree 100
with what you just said that jesse owens
active defiance i
and this is not me saying this so let me
be clear about that but the
the adage of shut up and run that's
literally what he did right he didn't he
didn't have a platform from which to
speak
didn't have the ability to speak but he
what he did have the ability to do
was say to to hitler and to the entire
world your concept of a super race
i will shatter that for all time right
and and did something
so deeply profound and i think that's
why i was asking the question earlier
about the
coming off in the brattiness right of
what when when barry did and i don't
mean that in any kind of misogynistic
way
just in terms of it did there's not a
clarity of message there's not a
clarity of authority the way that you
have it in some of these past
instances where someone i mean jesse
owens is representing an entire race of
people
in defiance of of a world leader who
would go on to wage war against the
entire world
in the name of this you know super race
and so um
i'll give you the last word here but but
is there a way
to still have these discussions that
elevates them and i want to say anthony
by the way just what a pleasure has been
by the way speaking with you because i
think you are
elevating the discussion in many clear
ways here but is there a way for these
athletes to elevate the discussion so
that it doesn't just become
this back and forth of america bad it
over
simplifies complicated issues i'll give
you the last word here
yeah yeah i i think that we saw that a
lot actually uh you know this
past summer with doc rivers you know um
nba basketball coach
and his his just very salient poignant
and powerful words
you know um i think that we saw that um
after uh
many play oh the um games were cancelled
right when nba players refuse to take
the uh take the court
when um a black man was shot in um uh i
believe is milwaukee wisconsin
and and that did foster uh the
discussion uh uh people like serena
williams are fostering that discussion
it's not it's not an easy one to have
you know um it's messy
and and and i think that uh what these
athletes are really um evoking is this
idea
of if we're going to move forward we are
going to have to get comfortable
with discomfort that's just the way it
is these these are not easy things to
talk about
these are not these are even harder
things to experience um and i would say
that you know
it's it's a choice that we all have to
make collectively and i would argue
that white america also needs to make
this choice of are you really ready to
have this conversation
because there's a there's a like just
like men you know we're
there are too many men not ready to have
that conversation at the height of the
me too era
and i think there are parallels with
white folk in the united states with
where we are in this era of black
liberation and indigenous liberation
if you're not comfortable having
uncomfortable discussions this is what's
going to continue
because i think what these athletes are
saying is that i am not going to place
your comfort level
over my liberation ever again and if you
can't handle that it's going to keep
happening until you can
it's it's it's a very very a beautiful
and brave thing to see
and i and i will agree with you that
clarity is very very important what we
saw in
ali was was absolute clarity right it
was lucid there
there was no um really no
dubiousness to what he was talking about
and what he was looking for and why he
was risking
what he did um more more conversations
will hopefully uh elucidate
uh what we're really talking about here
and bring us closer to that goal
of mutual justice for um all people
anthony rogers right thanks so much for
being with us it was a pleasure talking
to you
great to talk to we'll see you again
thank you well let's move the
conversation forward because
uh laverne spicer is going to join us
now she is a republican candidate
for office in florida and actually uh
has a very different point of view
laverne welcome to the podcast and i
guess i'll start with you
picking up on that clarity question
because quite candidly i don't get what
gwen berry was risking
i don't get what she was even trying to
say uh through this stance other than
looking like she was throwing a tantrum
um and no clarity to it perhaps you
you understand what it is welcome to the
show
um thank you ben for having me on
um first of all we're in america
and i think that america
is one of the greatest countries on
earth
that's how i feel about this country and
i know many people may you know feel the
same way that the gentleman did it just
spoke
but when you're a athlete
and you are representing this country
you have a choice to make you know when
you choose to represent this country
then if you have a problem with the flag
if you have a problem with different
things then go straight in that problem
out
if you don't want to be in this country
then you don't have to be
here
dan crenshaw who is a republican
congressman from texas
specifically said that he believes that
gwenberry should be removed from the u.s
olympic team do you agree with that
position yes i do
i do i feel like what she did was very
disrespectful
um to this country to the people
that support this country to the people
that love this country to the people
that love our flag
to the people that love our independence
and to the people that love america
that are pro-america that love being
here you know if you don't want to be
here
you don't want to represent us you don't
want to
uh salute or make the pledge allegiance
to the flag
then leave you don't have to be up there
what about the idea though that someone
like winbury has the ability to
to protest as an activist athlete
uh she's taking a stand again i'm not
sure what she was taking a stand
specifically for i don't think that was
ever made clear but
that the fact that she's able to do that
that on that podium
um that's something that's fairly unique
to the united states it's not going to
happen in other countries as we were
saying before
other countries would never allow
dissension
on their own olympic teams but does that
is that a positive in some ways do you
think for the united states or no
well first of all you know like you just
said we already know
um in other countries that type of um
of what can i call that nicely well that
type of reaction
would never be tolerated that would
never be tolerated
that's what made this country so great
because we have
the first amendment rights we have the
freedom of
speech we have the freedom to express
ourselves
but also if you standing up there
and you representing this country and
you hate this country so much
then you should not be representing this
country at all
you should be representing the country
that you feel
uh your um a deep connection with you
should be represented in the country
that you know that you feel is the best
country for you to be in
yeah i want to share something that um
yeah this this idea though that because
it's not just gwen berry obviously as we
mentioned you know there are other
athletes
as well who recently have said that that
they want to be on the olympic stage
just to burn the flag or to be able to
to to have some form of protest
and it feels to some extent look as
you're an athlete you're given a
platform you have the ability
to be able to communicate a message to
the world
but but shouldn't you be crystal clear
in whatever message you're trying to
send because some
generic message of america bad
it doesn't i just don't think it fits
not only is it inappropriate
but but there's no context to it why is
it bad right
the the idea that your own country would
even allow you to be
on a podium when you can throw this this
fit would wouldn't that
set it higher than other countries in
terms of
of your ability to to protest i mean as
we said there are other nations that
would never even consider
allowing you to do this
yes i think that's very disrespectful
you know
in more ways than one that's not just
disrespectful
to this country it's also disrespectful
to the people that you're supposed to be
on the same team
with i mean you know what type of
message is that send into them
the other two athletes by the way
because when barry came in third the
other two athletes who were first and
second
in this particular event no one's
talking about them
no one has anything to say about them we
don't even know their names
obviously their names are out there but
they but they're not being there's no
conversation surrounding them so
my question for you is do you believe
there is some form
of just attention-seeking uh through all
this that it's
it's about an athlete who you know
had she not done this no one would have
been talking about quite candidly
because
you know let's face it hammer throwing's
not exactly the most interesting
you know olympic sport would would there
be a less attention and is
part of this do you think an attention
seeking effort
well that's what it looked like it was
to be an attention seeking
effort you know if once again
you know to me it it if you got a
problem
or you don't like something state your
case
you know set set the menu for that state
your
case um and let it be known whatever
uh whatever it is that you are anti
or whatever it is you are protesting i'm
sure
it's a it could be a place for that um
i'm sure it could be agenda for that uh
whatever she want to create for that but
if you are up there you know and you
hate
this country and you are you want to
burn the flag
you know and you just want to throw a
fit i don't think that's
once again i don't think when you're
standing up there to represent our
country
why are you representing our country
if you are against the flag if you
hate the country that you are in leave
it's just that simple
in terms of the anthem itself the the
national anthem does have a
somewhat controversial history i mean if
you go back and read the actual anthem
the way it was originally written you go
to that third verse which we do not sing
it actually if and i've actually done
quite a bit of reporting on this in the
past it was back in
in uh 2016 or so when when the
kaepernick
uh controversy was pretty high and one
of the things that we find
in that in that third verse is actually
uh
delight in the idea that former slaves
who had gone and and essentially
were fighting against the united states
at that point it specifically talks
about
their deaths and and celebrating their
deaths
it is a very controversial uh verse
in that in that anthem as i said we
don't sing it but it is still a part of
that
is there not some level of of
um you know legitimate argument here
that maybe that
anthem isn't the right anthem to be
playing anymore
or now that we you know are reaching a
new point or do you think
that the anthem should remain as it is
well you know um i do believe i know
it's
that we have the national anthem
but we also have another
anthem that a lot of black people like
to sing
so i feel like you know whatever
uh everything you want to sing you sing
it
got it laverne spicer thank you so much
for your time and your insight on this
thank you van for having me on
absolutely
all right let's bring in dr paul
campbell he's the author of football
ethnicity and community and
uh paul let me just bring you in and
begin with that same question to you
about the anthem i mean there's been
a lot of discussion over the last couple
of years it not so much in
most recent like you know one or two
years but four or five years ago there
was a lot more discussion about the
anthem because of the fact
i think with with the kaepernick uh
kneeling during the anthem
what are the actual words what does it
say and there is uh language in there
i think that's troubling it's troubling
to to read it it's troubling
uh to see what what some of the the
kind of overall themes in that anthem
are
should athletes have to stand and listen
to that if they
object to it what is your opinion
um yeah and i think
i i don't think there's anything uh
unique
in the us anthem that is problematic the
anthems
generally celebrate a particular
narrative of the country of how it
presents itself and that always that
doesn't speak equally to
individuals um onto every individual in
the same way
um so in in that sense
it's probably unfair to expect
everybody particularly if they don't
feel
that that anthem speaks to them or
speaks to them in a particularly
um a kind of unequal way
kind of expecting them to kind of stand
there and salute
this anthem in the same way as everybody
else
however the problem with sport is it's
hard it's tied into our identity it's
tied into
ideas of patriotism and so whenever
anybody
challenges the kind of anthem
it's not seen as them kind of
communicating or expressing
their almost their patriotism in saying
that actually
we want the country to work for us but
it doesn't it's seen as some sort of
attack
on the national project
yeah i i think there is uh there's there
are a lot of questions
about the anthem itself but let's take
the conversation a little more broad
back to some of these other points
because
you're you're specifically your book you
know football ethnicity and community
you're you're talking about i think the
rise of
of activist athletes that's one of the
the things that stood out to me about
the gwen berry story was that at one
point during the anthem
she put a a t-shirt over her head and it
says activist athlete
is is there a you know expectation
whether it's right or not an expectation
that if you are an activist athlete
that you have a clarity to your message
and a clarity to what you're trying to
say
because otherwise don't you just begin
to look like you are
um you know kind of riding the train of
activist athletes without actually
putting any real skin in the game
um i think i think it often depends
there's a whole set of factors one
for example of that community uh also so
that symbolism becomes all the more
powerful um
if you're if you're of that community
um and and this idea that kind of
and it's a common one that's used
particularly to attack
activists that they shouldn't be
speaking of
the plights of other people because
often they are
well paid and we see this particularly
with colin kaepernick and
and others across different kinds of
sporting clients
that actually they don't have legitimacy
in highlighting these issues but
what we need to recognize is that these
athletes are
part of these communities they have
family they have
friends so actually the fact that
they have had this platform um in many
ways is their skin in the game because
often
in making these um in these protests
they often risk that platform
and and those privileges that often
people suggest
means that they can't make these these
protests
so so they have they do have a kind of
skin in the game
but it's just a different kind of of
of of of of kind of um
skin in the game to to use that term
okay so let me let me push back on that
a bit because i i hear what you're
saying right
you have the right as an activist to
speak up right regardless of whether or
not you're making millions of dollars
and you you are wealthy and you are
quote-unquote privileged
uh but you're speaking on behalf of
people who are not right you're speaking
on behalf of those that that society is
is stepping on and so
you're using your platform i get all of
that the question is
have we now reached a moment where it
doesn't
cost as much to be an activist in
particular areas
as it did at one time so as we were
talking in the earlier discussion
you know there there is a a history of
certain athletes who have taken stands
at great cost to themselves uh in order
to take those stance
are we still in that moment or are we
living in a moment where it's
fashionable
where where you know sponsors
and big corporations don't run away from
athletes who are activists they flock to
them
to sign them to deals i think we have to
be careful here because
um different athletes for example have
different responses so we can't kind of
generalize across
everybody um what we see is is so for
example if we go back to
john carlos in 1968 he was
um him and tommy smith were widely
condemned
not only were they not allowed to to
continue to to be athletes or picked for
the u.s scene
but they even found um that they
couldn't uh find
work for for deck you know for for
decades afterwards
um but we are seeing those kinds of
sanctions on players i i think it's
very very um uh kind of
dangerous ground to try to say that
actually all athletes
um are now a place where actually
activism
is good for their careers i don't think
in
any in any way that
activism is good for anybody's career
and we've seen this with
colin kaepernick we've seen this with
in the english context around soccer and
taking the knee
we've seen that the kind of social media
backlash and the the racism
and the the kind of attacks the players
that take
uh these kinds of positions receive
so i think in in some cases yes sponsors
and parts of the the media are much more
sensitive and uh accommodating of
athletes in trying to make their kind of
protests and their moral position
but equally i think on the whole we see
governing bodies
we see state organizations particularly
sporting governing bodies
still trying to sanction players and and
kind of clamp down
on on these kinds of activities because
sport
often presents itself as being an a
space it's a space
where politics has no place
and do you think that we'll continue to
see more athletes take these kinds of
stands
in the future and it and and will it
become more commonplace
uh as we move forward
i think that's what's really interesting
about this kind of movement
and this moment that we've seen
particularly
sort of when we look at the nba which
has always been kind of
a different different and maybe that's
because of
the the kind of power and the the
demographic
of the players um but we've seen
in other sports a a momentum
so i i wouldn't be surprised and i'd
probably
welcome um players feeling
that this is the moment where they can
actually finally use their platforms and
we've seen this
not just in relation to race we've seen
this in relation to kind of lgb
see uh uh discriminations with
megan rappano and and manuel neuer
in the current world cup um
so i think that we will see more people
taking
uh using this platform but equally
um i think we're also seeing a rise in
the kind of
backlash particularly on social media
and
and so for example and particularly with
the embodies such as the
the ioc who are taking a particularly
hard line
position so i think what we are going to
see is just
more instances of clash between players
and certain governing bodies
dr paul campbell author of football
ethnicity and community thank you so
much for your time today
thank you yeah guys i i think it's a
it's a fascinating
uh discussion about where we go from
there and and honestly the question of
whether or not you know there is a a
industry that is forming surrounding
activism
because that becomes kind of corporate
sanctioned activism and i gotta say you
know as a journalist
i have covered activism and activists
for many many years
across uh different countries and
different uh belief systems and what
they were fighting for and one thing you
find about activism is
it's so different depending on where you
find yourself and who you're connected
to
what's fascinating about the moment
we're in right now is it seems that
there
is kind of a corporate sanctioned
activism listed to a few
very narrow positions a few very narrow
belief systems
and that's now acceptable and that
actually can pay quite well
and the rest of activism doesn't
necessarily fit into that as long as you
buck that corporate line
uh you're not going to be successful in
terms of those controls so
uh it's definitely worth something
watching and keeping an eye on and we
will continue
to do so guys thanks for watching and
we'll be back here next week
a whole new subject we'll do it again 11
a.m eastern time on the no bs podcast
see you then
[Music]
you